I just finished cleaning my house
and I'd like it to stay that way
so I figured the best course of action
was to completely evacuate the city
and go mess up somebody else's
the ferry ride turned into a free whale watching expedition
and I've never seen dolphins in this harbour
so my inner child was squealing
alongside my actual children
we're heading to waiheke Island
which if you don't already know
is a small rock of the coast of Auckland here in Aotearoa, New Zealand
and I'm lucky because my mum lives here
so it's close enough to visit
but also there's an ocean between us
Just the way I like it
the foot gag is unfortunately in my DNA
and I was pleased I let
my 5 year old convinced me she could pack
her own essentials for the trip
I wanna eat my dinner in peace later
so we burnt off some energy at the beach
it turns out
even if you spend your entire life teaching your children not to throw sand
they will, in fact, throw sand
we should have named Goldie Ken
because she thinks her job is beach
and she takes it very seriously
at this point I realised
I possibly could have thought through my pre-dinner beach plan a little better
cause by the time the youngins were tired out
they were also wet sandy and starving
and then Goldie just chewed through her lead
so I was good and ready for that g&t